c'est décidé j'entreprends écologique ça
fait rêver ça fait un peu peur aussi
sans compter la légère pression qu'on se
met tout à coup sûr les épaules
c'est pourtant ce que j'ai fait il ya
quatre ans à ce moment là j'étais à la
tête d'un institut de sondages et
d'études marketing
c'était un job carrément léger amusant
même puisque j'avais spécialisé notre
activité dans la mesure de la
satisfaction des visiteurs dans les
parcs de loisirs et d'attractions
tout un programme et autant vous dire
que j'ai été élu pendant plusieurs
années consécutives meilleur mamans du
monde par mes trois enfants mais ça me
suffisait plus je me retrouvais plus
j'avais même l'impression de me perdre
j'avais plus en plus le besoin de me
dire que je devais mettre faire que mon
activité professionnelle est un sens
soit utile mais une fois qu'on a posé sa
foi toujours évident de trouver l'idée
qui va vous permettre de mettre du sens
dans votre activité professionnelle et
un jour mon lave linge tombe en panne
mauvais timing puisque ça se passe juste
à la fin de la période de garantie
c'est ballot donc ben je vais venir un
réparateur il vient y regarde démontre
l'appareil et regarde encore réfléchi
gratte un peu la tête il se gratte le
menton et le verdict tombe sans appel
cet appareil il faudra le changer on
pourra pas le réparer
ou plutôt pour être un peu plus exact on
pourrait éventuellement le réparer mais
ça prendrait très longtemps et ça
coûterait bien plus cher qu'un appareil
neuf en tant que consommatrice
mais bon j'ai pas trop le choix je
m'incline
je suis piégé mais je vous ai déjà parlé
de mes trois enfants non en tant que
citoyenne je me dis que c'est plus
possible qu'on peut pas continuer comme
ça qu'on va droit dans le mur
est ce que vous savez que si l'humanité
suivait le même mode de vie que qu'un
français moyen
aujourd'hui il faudrait 2,9 planètes
pour subvenir à ses besoins
alors on fait quoi on continue on
regarde pas sur les côtés on va tout
droit
et on se dit que peut-être qu'une
technologie magique va arriver et tout
gommé où on agit
et au niveau de notre consommation
on continue à cautionner le
développement de ces horribles et
interminable zone commerciale à l'entrée
à la sortie des villans ni vin ni dans
nos achats ch a justement ces achats de
produits industrialisés qu'on fait par
milliers des produits dont on n'a pas
forcément besoin et qui souvent ont fait
le tour du monde pour arriver jusqu'à
nous on fait quoi bon continuer à les
acheter ou on commence à regarder les
étiquettes et peut-être à réduire sa
consommation
bref j'en étais là une consommatrice
dépité et une citoyenne carrément en
colère et là il ya la troisième mois
l'entrepreneur qui justement cherché à
mettre de l'impact est un maître du sens
dans cette activité professionnelle qui
se dit qu'elle a peut-être trouvé le
sujet que c'est peut-être là la mission
qu'elles devraient suivre et alors
malgré ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là on
bosse on se met à bosser sérieusement et
à essayer de comprendre
première question c'était de savoir
pourquoi l'électroménager il ya 40 ans
étaient construits pour durer et
qu'aujourd'hui il est plus fait que pour
être changée reste question
alors on a exploré analyse est recherché
on a décortiqué les modèles économiques
des entreprises du secteur
on a suivi la piste de la
désindustrialisation de la france
on a aussi regardé
qui se passait du côté de la réparation
et tout ce qu'on a trouvé n'a fait que
confirmer notre intuition
on avait le sujet et c'était le moment
de changer
mais une fois qu'une fois tout ça tout
ça pose et il faut se dire que même
quand on a la bonne idée quand elle nous
tient vraiment à coeur
investir et se lancer dans une
entreprise ex nihilo a fortiori une
entreprise industrielle mais je pense
que le sujet est peut être comme un
atout c'est pas forcément si facile il
faut de l'audace du collège avoir envie
de prendre des risques
une très forte volonté aussi et puis je
pense qu'il faut aussi croire à sa
chance et savoir la saisir
ma première chance à moi ça a été de
découvrir mais totalement par hasard sur
linkedin une entreprise dont la
spécialité était de vendre des instituts
de sondage tel que le mien et match
la prise de chance a été vain de leur
confier la vente de mon institut la
prise de risques derrière ça a été de
réinvestir l'argent recueilli dans sept
nouveaux dans ce nouveau projet et me
lance t et d'y aller à fond jusqu'au
bout sans craindre d'être radical sans
craindre de ne pas suivre les modèles
qui existent tout simplement parce que
ces modèles existent et parce que c'est
les seuls qu'on nous a enseigné notre
sujet à nous c'était la durabilité
alors on a construit un modèle où tout
devait être durable durable
les produits bien sûr évidemment ça va
de soi c'est logique
sauf que c'est pas totalement sans
conséquences au niveau économique
puisque les produits qu'on fabrique on
les vendra qu'une seule fois après il
sera toujours plus logique de les
réparer
que de l'échangé pourquoi plus logique
ben parce que ça sera plus rapide moins
cher et plus efficace
donc les produits hockey tchèque mais ça
ne suffit pas il fallait aussi que notre
action elle soit durable vis-à-vis de la
planète
et là encore il a fallu tout remettre à
plat tout repensé pour que du mode des
modes de production au choix des
fournisseurs au choix des matériaux au
choix des technologies qu'on va employer
tout un os pour objectif de limiter au
maximum notre l'empreinte de notre
activité sur la planète
après il ya un autre sujet qui était
important c'est que tout ça ça ne peut
être durable que si on prend en
considération les femmes et les hommes
impliqués dans l'aventuré et pour ça il
a fallu repenser à nouveau la manière
d'organiser la structure sans table en
mettant tout sur la table en ayant juste
un objectif être socialement responsable
être inclusif mais aussi créer des
emplois les emplois pérennes locaux au
niveau social on s'est aussi interrogé
sur la gouvernance sans tabou une fois
encore et là c'est peut-être ça sera
peut-être le sujet d'une autre
conférence parce que on n'a pas encore
trouvé la voie mais en tout cas on la
cherche
les produits l'action par rapport à la
planète
les hommes et les femmes impliquées dans
la société et il nous manquait un
quatrième pied c'est les consommateurs
alors une relation un sens unique
fournisseur client
non merci c'est pas notre sujet et puis
on voit bien ce que ça donne aujourd'hui
nous on est convaincu que c'est le
collectif qui fera bouger les choses et
le collectif pour pour s'impliquer il
faut qu'on lui ouvre la porte et qu'on
lui donne la possibilité de s'impliquer
on qu'on lui donne la possibilité de
s'investir de questionner les équipes de
propos de faire des propositions et donc
on a choisi de créer une communauté une
communauté d'utilisateurs qui est un
point d'accès à l'entreprise un point
d'accès ça veut dire quoi eh ben ça veut
dire que les membres de cette communauté
ils vont pouvoir s'impliquer nous
questionner proposés mais aussi partager
entre eux apprendre à se connaître
recréer du commun de la proximité et
ainsi peut-être en prenant ce chemin on
va réussir à changer le monde en
commençant par l'électroménager changer
de trajectoire pour changer la société
je les fais c'est possible c'est
possible même si on est une femme
c'est possible même si on n'a pas
l'expérience requise c'est possible même
si on n'a pas la formation c'est
possible même si même si même si même si
c'est possible que ça en vaut la peine
parce qu'aujourd'hui ben fut plus ni
député ni en colère
le message que je voudrais partager
aujourd'hui c'est soyez ouverts regarder
observer osé ça en vaut la peine et la
planète en a besoin
merci beaucoup